tim mcgraw stops his concert mid-song to
confront some hecklers in the audience
[Music]
during his performance over the weekend
at the nugget event center in reno the
54 year old country crooner took a pause
while singing his hit 1997 track where
the green grass grows after fumbling
over some of the lyrics in the video tim
appears to brush off the lyrical misstep
before he stops singing altogether
stands up straight looks right at some
concert goers and jumps off the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you can hear the audience chanting
his name
[Applause]
but ultimately he returned to the stage
to keep the show going
[Music]
[Applause]
while we don't know the details of
exactly what went down there we do know
tim has been very busy see there you go
earlier this month the grammy winner and
his wife faith hill celebrated their
25th wedding anniversary she's a strong
woman he's a great role model for our
daughters for having three daughters you
know she's she's the perfect role model
the best role model in him can have
she
has a heart just as big as her voice to
commemorate the day tim shared on
instagram the sweet story of how he
proposed saying he popped the question
at a music festival right before his
performance i went to stage and did the
show and then i came off the stage and
went back into my dressing room and
faith wasn't there but i looked at the
mirror in lipstick and said yes
i'm going to be your wife
and we still have that mirror and it was
a
best day of my life that's for sure
the pair is also set to star in the
yellowstone prequel series 1883 for
paramount plus alongside sam elliott and
billy bob thornton who opened up to e.t
about his role last month i just went
and did a cameo it's two two little
scenes and
old friends were making it and
[Music]
they wrote a cameo that they said they
needed a movie guy for
and uh would i come to it and i was
happy to go do it because i got to see
sam elliott who uh go way back
and tim and faith i've known for a long
time so
it was a lot of fun i went down there
shot the place up and got out of fort
worth